Oi, meu nomé é Clayton Christensen e sou professor da Harvard Business School
eu trouxe comigo um conjunto de ferramentas, todas relacionadas com inovação
nos decidimos que a maneira que ensinamos marketing
estava equivocada
a melhor forma que encontramos até agora
é que as pessoas na verdade alugam produtos para completar tarefas
e entender quais
tarfefas elas têm que fazer para o qual alugariam os produtos
é realmente o ponto chave para melhorar como ensinamos marketing
como os clientes
se sentem motivados para comprar o que oferecemos
eu gostaria então de contar
uma historia sobre um projeto que fizemos para uma grande cadeia de restaurantes
eles estavam tentando aumentar as vendas de milkshakes
eles iniciaram estudando os clientes trazendo para um focus group
que estivessem dentro do perfil de consumidor de milkshake
eles deram exemplos de milskhakes e perguntaram se poderiam dizer como melhorar o
milkshake e se eles comprariam mais
se estivesse com mais chocolate, mais barato, com pedaços,etc
e receberam excelentes feedbacks de como poderiam melhorar nas
dimensões mencionadas, mas não teve nenhum impacto nas vendas e lucros
então um de nosso colegas foi até um dos restaurantes com uma pergunta em mente
que era
relacionada a porque as pessoas visitavam o restaurante
para comprar
milkshake
então ficamos por 18 horas no restaurante e tomamos nota
de vários dados
que horas eles foram comprar os milkshakes? o que eles estavam vestindo ? estavam sozinhos ?
se compraram algo mais ? como saíram para dirigir com eles ?
descobriu-se que quase a metade da
milkshakes foram vendidos antes das 8
da manhã
e as pessoas que compraram estavam sempre sozinhas e tinha sido a única coisa que compraram
e entravam no carro e iam embora
para tentar descobrir qual tarefa eles estavam realizar, por alugar o produto (milkshake)
voltamos no dia seguinte e ficamos
fora do restaurante para que pudéssemos
falar com essas pessoas como milkshake na mão
e em linguagem que podiam
entender que, essencialmente, perguntamos:
"desculpe-me por favor, mas eu gostaria de entender uma coisa
qual tarefa você está tentando fazer para você mesmo que fez com que você viesse aqui
para comprar o milkshake"
foi meio difícil eles responderem então começamos a perguntar outras coisas
"pense na última vez que estava na mesma situação
a necessidade de obter o mesmo trabalho feito e que você não veio aqui para comprar um milkshake
o que você comprou (ou alugou) ?"
depois colocamos todas as respostas
juntas e ficou claro que todos eles
tinham a mesma tarefa para realizar logo de manhã
que era uma longo e chata viagem de carro até o trabalho
e eles precisavam de algo que os ajudasse na viagem
uma mão tinha que estar no volante
e na outra mão não tinha nada, estava livre
e eles só precisava de algo para fazer enquanto
eles dirigiram
eles não estavam com fome ainda, mas eles sabiam eles estariam com fome por 10 horas, para que
queriam algo que os mantivesse alimentado até lá
boa pergunta, o que eu compro(alugo) para realizar esta tarefa
que eu não percebi antes
última sexta feira eu tentei banana para me ajudar durante a viagem
"por favor nunca tente com bananas"
"acabou em 3 minutos e estaria com fome as 7:30"
"se você prometer que não vai contar à minha esposa que eu comprei donuts quase duas vezes por semana"
"eles não fazem bem e na verdade eles se foram
rápidamente e sujou toda minha roupa"
"deixaram meus dedos oleosos"
"algumas vezes comprei bagels, mas você sabe eles são tão secos e sem gosto"
"e eu tenho que dirigir o carro com o meus
joelhos e não dá para colocar geléia e depois"
"se o telefone tocar será um desastre"
"me lembro de comprar um snickers uma vez"
"me senti tão culpado que nunca comprei
snickers novamente"
"deixe-me dizer-lhe quando cheguei o porque do milkshake"
"é tão viscoso"
"que levo quase 20 minutos para tomá-lo"
"quem se importa com o que os ingredientes ? eu não"
"a única coisa que sei é que é de manhã e que o copo cabe direitinho no meu porta copos"
o que acontece é que o milkshake faz
o trabalho
melhor do que qualquer um dos
concorrentes (alimentos)
que, nas mentes dos clientes não são
os milkshakes do Burger King, mas tem sido os
snickers, bagels, cafés e etc
espero que você possa ver como se você
compreender o trabalho (tarefa)
como fica óbvio melhorar o produto!!!